Speaker 1: All right.
I have a couple of quick stories to briefly
talk about.
This is an interesting one.
It is now appearing that Donald Trump has
been desperate to appear on Joe Rogan's podcast
and that Joe Rogan has turned him down.
We're going to look at a clip of Rogan himself
explaining this.
There's a Daily Beast article.
Joe Rogan reveals he's rejected Trump multiple
times for interview.
Rogan recently declared his support for Ron
DeSantis.
On Tuesday, he said he's absolutely no Trump
fan and has no desire to assist them in any
way, shape or form.
This was on a podcast with host Lex Friedman,
and Rogan talked about how weird the Trump
era is going to be in retrospect.
Some of the reasons Rogan cited are not ones
I agree with.
But that's okay.
Let's listen to what Joe Joe Rogan had to
say about Trump wanting to be on his show.
Speaker 2: By the way, I'm not a Trump supporter
in any way, shape or form.
I've had the opportunity to have on my show
more than once.
I've said no every time and I want to help
him.
I'm not interested in helping now.
Speaker 1: One interesting question is whether
such an interview would be a good interview
for someone like Joe Rogan and his show.
Because when you think about the Rogan format,
which is three hour conversations and I've
been on for two of them on his show, often
in depth and sort of flighty.
Non sequential thinking.
Is not very conducive to those types of conversations.
And this is what Trump does.
You ask him about one thing and you say, Hey,
you know what?
What's the deal with you?
I heard you like fast food.
Yeah, well, you know, KFC, you know, they
make it.
They make a tremendous bird.
And but the thing is, you know, the Democrats
and radical Joe Biden, they want to control
everything.
Not only did he lose, he wants to take away
burgers.
And I mean, we just you just can't have it.
And I said I would fix it.
I would fix all of it.
I would fix trade.
You know, it's it's not he's not even really
able to have that type of a conversation.
And, you know, the speculation of Trump with
adult ADHD or whatever, I think the guy just
has no idea what's going on in any serious
depth with any topic.
I think that's really the explanation.
And Trump would ramble on and interrupt and
interject about the election stolen or whatever.
So from like a conversational standpoint,
I don't know how Trump does a three hour conversation
with Rogan.
That's not a praise or a criticism of the
format.
I think it's a great thing.
It's great to have podcasts of all different
formats, and the three hour conversation is
a great format for people who can do it.
It doesn't seem to me that that Trump could
do it now in terms of Rogan doesn't want to
help Trump, as I've said before, I don't think
there is any like big mystery about Rogan.
I think Rogan admits he's not the most keyed
into politics and Rogan, to a degree, is a
chameleon of sorts.
When I was on his show and I espoused all
of my left wing ideas, Joe agreed with almost
everything I had to say.
And then when he has on, you know, whoever
from the right, he agrees generally with most
of the things they have to say.
He's had disagreements that I've covered with
people, like he's had disagreements with Ben
SHAPIRO on some things.
He's had disagreements with Candace Owens,
you know, right wingers in a sense.
And to a degree, I think that what's happening
with Rogan is he is, um, when it comes to
a lot of different areas, he is clearly on
the left when you get into the details.
I think he genuinely is.
I think he's also culturally conservative.
A lot of the circles he's now in, you know,
UFC and Dana White, definite right wing bent
there.
He's now in Texas and reportedly, I think
has a relationship with the governor there,
Greg Abbott, who's an extreme right winger.
He's in this environment where there's a lot
of kind of de facto right wing thinking.
And then like on DeSantis, I just think he's
sort of confused.
I don't even think Rogan is aware that DeSantis
stands for the opposite of most of the things
Rogan has espoused support for.
So I don't think we need to get into this
thing of like ascribing a significant morality
to it.
I think politics isn't Rogan's main thing,
and he finds common ground with almost anyone
he talks to.
And while he is socially liberal to a great
degree, he's also in a culturally conservative
environment and that rubs off on him.
So interesting for sure how much we glean
from it about anything in particular other
than Trump's desperation to get on Rogan's
podcast, which is interesting, is probably
not to too much